[Music]
Kim Kardashian slams ad andhe's house
co-founder Rhymefest for saying Kanye
abandoned Chicago that is hard for me
the 37 year old reality star had a busy
holiday weekend defending her man after
Kanye's former music collaborator and
charity partner took to Twitter to
attack the rapper alleging Kanye left
the nonprofit organization the two
started in 2011 to pay tribute to
Kanye's late mother
Don de West and served the youth of his
hometown of Chicago high and dry
tweeting I'm asking Drake to help the
part of Chicago Kanye has abandoned I
spoke to Kanye about it his response was
the youth of Chicago though Kanye has
yet to respond kim wasted no time firing
back tweeting in part stop with your
fake community politics and lies truth
is you haven't been able to sustain the
foundation you better believe I will
make it my mission to take tantas house
from you and let my children run it the
way it should be run I will always ride
for my man I love that on Saturday the
charity announced they were letting go
of the name releasing this statement due
to recent events we have decided to no
longer use the name jaundice House Inc
the social media quotes from Kim
Kardashian West as well as the expressed
interest of her family running the
organization has brought us to this
decision just days prior to the beef
with Rhymefest
Kim's hubby came under fire from Whitney
Houston's cousin Damon Elliot for using
a photo of the late singer's drug strewn
bathroom as the cover of Pusha T's new
album which Kanye is the producer of and
it was reported he bought the photo
originally published by the National
Enquirer in 2006 for a whopping eighty
five thousand dollars Damon who is the
son of Whitney's aunt Dionne Warwick
says the family was not consulted about
the use of the photo and told people
Kanye's use of the
is quote absolutely disgusting petty and
tacky
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]